bonjour et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation avant d'évoquer ce second
tour est ce que l'important ce n'est pas
cette transition pacifique inédite dans
le pays je rappelle que fait rare sur le
continent et surtout au niger mahamadou
issoufou n'était pas candidat à cette
présidentielle
oui ce qui est important c'est déjà le
fait que le président mahamadou issoufou
et c'est que son parti ait compris
qu'ils avaient des septs et de passer la
main d'organiser délicate transition en
président élu est une entreprise d'un
élu lucho est important c'est que on est
parent est bien celle tradition du coup
ko c'est à dire que la victoire des
cours qui aurait pu être mal perçu parce
que il ya un opposant qui n'a pas pu se
présenter pour des raisons légales et
qui n'a pas appelé justement à quoi
c'était le scrutin et la dignité voir à
manx ban qui est long le le delluc
attaqué leurs positions
il n'y a pas eu de n'y a pas eu comme
dans cette baie une exclusion ressentie
comme victimaire de la part de cet
opposant dans cet intrigant pas
également est le dernier grand pas que
je voulais souligner c'est que il ya eu
cette volonté dans une partie de
l'opposition de contester sa nationalité
aux candidats bien des stars ya on voit
qu'avec son score son mot d'ordre la
patrie même s'il n'a pas gagné comme les
ours mot d'ordre 48 donc même logique
nationaliste par moments qui consiste à
jouer sur les origines des candidats
pour disqualifier n'a pas du tout pris
olivia cette année on l'a vu lever des
alliances semble incontournable pour le
second tour mais au niger ces alliances
se font et se défont en rapidement il ya
eu beaucoup de coups d'état cela annonce
des négociations compliquées
je crois que
le corps qui n'est pas très qui n'est
pas très proche de 50% du candidat qui
est arrivé coeur hanté il sera là il
faudrait un néo gothique ou l'impossible
façon ferme pour trouver les alliances
faire les plus de 50% nécessaires pour
être élu
les 1ères public cependant je crois que
ne ce ne sera pas très compliqué on leur
montre de temps sur ces sur cet accord
qui lui permettra de gagner je voulais
battre c'est sûr il trouvera le plus
facilement les accords m il pense que
tout cela va se trouver car on n'est pas
du continent africain où la laddh est
très important on discute énormément ou
un s'arrange pour avoir une certaine
forme de consensus nous c'est beaucoup
de coups d'état donc je n'ai pas de
doute sur le fait que la campagne qu'ils
s'engagent soit d'abord précédée par un
lot de négociations en coulisse pour
permettre aux candidats de trouver
toutes les boîtes faire le plein des
voix dans les réserves qui restent
mohamed bazoum donc aux ententes pour ce
second tour est ce que c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour le peuple nigérien je
crois que c'est au delà de moi même pas
où mme ce qui est récompensée et si
c'est la gestion du pays telle qu'elle a
été fait par le pnns pendant dix ans
ensuite par la gestion même comme
mohamed bazoum et puis le programme
qu'il a proposé c'est tout cela à la
fois qui est récompensée et ce n'est pas
un hasard si c'est le premier président
démocratiquement élu du pays mamadou
ousmane qui est son adversaire pour le
second tour c'est à dire qu'on a affaire
à deux hommes politiques de poids avec
deux formations politiques qui les
accompagnent et que le vécu de la est
l'hôte feront la différence les jeux
sont complètement ouvert espérons que
c'est des classes est cette lumière
démocratique qui s'allument au niger va
se prolonger jusqu'au second tour
jusqu'à la victoire
après le second tour du 2 février
prochain une second tour qui on l'espère
se passera dans des conditions
pacifiques
il y a ces nouvelles deux heures de
nombreuses personnes ont été tuées hier
par des hommes armés at home au bon goût
est ce que vous redoutez que d'autres
types de violence se passe encore
jusqu'à ce second tour le 20 février
mais ça va être la dernière élection
avant cinq ans au niger on remarqua que
les élections locales se sont passées
sans aucune violence que toute la
campagne pour les législatives et la
présidentielle parce que c'est un
scrutin couplé se sont passées sans
aucune violence et que même le jour des
élections etc a pas eu de violences
cela dit on est dans un autre contexte
du sel qui est celui du terrorisme
l'unige et à au moins trois points dans
lesquelles ils le lui aux trois points
auxquels il lutte contre le terrorisme
il ya d'abord la libye nous voir et on
or il ya le sel à l'ouest avec tout
l'été à liszt qui s'y trouvent
et puis elle à l'est il nous faut écrire
dans la zone du lac tchad par beaucoup à
20 dont il ya trois foyers tension ce
n'est pas surprenant que par mort cela
et klaus
cela dit a pas de foyers à l'intérieur
du niger même qui représente une menace
sécuritaire 60 des menaces virtuelles
extérieur et qui sont peu ou prou
contenu par les autorités merci beaucoup
louis keumayou pour toutes ces
précisions je rappelle que vous êtes
président du club de l'information
africaine merci à vous